hello everyone
this talk is going to be about the
broadcast channel
which is a very popular and a very well
studied model that captures wireless
communication
wireless communication is in fashion it
is everywhere
but it is also prone to noise and it is
actually more noisy than
a communication over a standard wire and
as a consequence
research that naturally focused on
studying the noisy broadcast channel
where you want
wireless communication that is resilient
to the noise in the channel
a lot of work went into this direction
we have nice upper and lower bounds
and in this paper what we want to
consider is we want to consider a second
aspect of the wireless channel which is
the presence of malicious parties
we say that wireless communication may
happen over a large distributed system
where there are end parties
and not all of these parties may be
perfectly synchronized maybe some
parties have some faults maybe some
parties fail during the protocol
or maybe some parties are just malicious
and
ideally a protocol over a wireless
channel or the broadcast channel should
be resilient to both
the noise in the channel which is random
and
the malicious parties which may be
adversarial and this is how we want to
do computation over the noisy broadcast
channel
this is the main result of this paper we
show how to do computation over the
noisy broadcast channel even when there
are malicious parties
but before i state this result more
formally let's just overview the
definitions first
so the object of study will be the
broadcast channel and we will study the
classic problem of grid exchange
that was proposed by aldemar in 1987
the description is pretty simple there
are n parties each party
party i has an input x i and the goal of
all the parties is to know all the input
bits so
every party wants to output the vector x
which is x1 x2 all the way to xn
now in order to output this vector they
need to communicate between themselves
and this communication will proceed in
synchronous rounds in each round
we will have a fixed party which is a
speaker and all the other parties will
be listeners
and the speaker is restricted to
transmit or broadcast
the same bit to all the other parties
and this is actually the part where
wireless comes in because when you have
a wireless router that is sending
packets then it does not really know the
receiver all it knows
is that it's sending patents into the
atmosphere and everybody in this room
will receive the same packet
so that's the wireless part um the same
packet is sent to all the neighbors all
the parties
if the channel is noiseless then this
packet or this bit will be received
correctly
but if the channel is noisy then
there is some noise parameter epsilon
and with probability epsilon
independently for each party
the bit that they receive will be
flipped and with the remaining
probability one minus epsilon the bit
will be received directly okay
so how do you solve widgets change over
the broadcast channel
turns out when there is no noise then
there is a simple enron protocol
there are n parties each party simply
takes one round to broadcast its bit
and because there is no noise the
broadcast will be received directly and
everybody will solve bit exchange
when there is noise there is a
protocol that i'll call the trivial
protocol or the naive protocol
where the parties simply broadcast their
bit login times
instead of one and because each party
broadcasts its bit login times
the other parties can do majority
decoding
and this will be current except with
probability polynomial is smaller than
now this probability is so small that
you can union bound over all the bits
and all the parties
and you get a protocol that takes n log
in rounds or enlarging bits of
communication and solves bit exchange
except the probability of nobody smaller
than
can we do better yes we can there is a
very clever protocol
due to gallagher um the study in a
classic protocol from the 80s and
it takes only n log loading rounds to
solve bridges change over the noisy
channel
and this is actually an exponential
improvement if you look at it in terms
of the communication by one player
in the trivial protocol a given player
in this
channel was sending login bits it was
repeating its with log in times
but dialer only requires it to repeat
log log in time so it's an exponential
improvement
and this is the best you can get
there is a matching lower bound that
shows this is tight after constant
factors
but
what this protocol has is this property
that even if
there's only one malicious party in this
system
then this protocol completely breaks
down and in the presence of malicious
parties we will see why it breaks down
uh later in the talk but in the presence
of malicious parties the best protocol
you have
is the naive protocol where you repeat
your bit login times
our main result is that you can do
better our main result is a quadratic
improvement we show that there is a
protocol where each player communicates
only square root login bits
there are some lot lot factors that i
will ignore so the total communication
is n
times square root log it solves with
exchange
under the presence of noise and even
when up to half the parties are
malicious
so let's let's see what does it mean to
solve british change when up to half the
parties are malicious
well if there were no malicious parties
then usually solving with exchange
would require um all the parties to
output
all the bits of all the other parties
directly
with a very high probability let's say
one minus one or poly n
but in the presence of malicious parties
this requirement is
too to be true for two reasons
the first reason is that some parties
are just malicious and even if they
cooperate perfectly even if they
follow the protocol correctly throughout
the protocol when it comes to outputting
something they may intentionally output
the wrong thing
and thus you cannot get all the parties
talk with the
right thing even if they are agreeing
and this is just because the malicious
parties will output the wrong thing at
the end of the protocol
so can we require all the honest parties
or all the non-malicious parties to
output the right thing
well turns out even this is too much and
this is too much for a different reason
this is because throughout the protocol
a malicious party whose input is zero
may be pretending as if its input was a
one
and any non-malicious or any honest
party cannot tell the difference
so you cannot expect an honest party to
output directly the bit of a malicious
party
and you can also not expect a malicious
party to output any bit directly
so the strongest possible requirement
that you can have
is that all the honest parties output
the bits of all the other honest parties
correctly with high probability this is
the requirement that we work with
and we are able to get a protocol that
satisfies this requirement the strongest
possible
in a computationally efficient way um
by efficient i mean that their end
parties and the algorithms that these
parties run locally
run in polynomial time in fact in our
protocol they run in near linear time so
that's pretty cool
but even above and beyond this theorem
our paper pushes a very important idea
which is that of property preserving
interactive coding
interactive coding is just a fancy term
for making protocols resilient to noise
and what we say here is that there is a
trivial protocol that is very wasteful
in communication it takes and lodging
rounds
but it has other nice properties because
you simply repeat and you decode the
majority
malicious parties do not really affect
this protocol everybody is just doing
their own thing so it does not matter
whether there are malicious parties or
not
um this protocol is also computationally
efficient because all you need to do
is to broadcast your bit and take
majorities
and these are all nice properties that
are there for the struggle protocol
and i usually what interactive coding
and noise resident protocols have
is they want to minimize the
communication they want a protocol that
communicates as few bits as possible
but they're willing to compromise on all
these other properties
what our theorem shows is that this
compromise is not necessary
you can actually have a protocol that
minimizes the communication it is lower
it was enlarged now it sends square root
blood in
but it keeps all the other properties
intact so it's property preserving
this new protocol is also resilient to
malicious players it is also
computationally efficient
and maybe these if these properties are
what you're
after then even if these properties are
what you're after you don't have to
suffer the lot in overhead you can do a
square root plotting over it
okay so that's pretty cool
and in the rest of this thought i will
talk about the ideas that go behind this
theorem and i'll actually present almost
a complete proof with some minor
calculations listening
and in order to start let me first
formalize
um the trivial protocol where players
broadcast a lot in times and detours by
majority i will
use this to build up to galaxy's
protocol and so
let us it will be helpful in setting up
notation i want
to view the trivial protocol as a
two-stage process
i want the first stage to be where each
player simply broadcasts its input login
times this is
stage broadcast and i want the second
stage to be
where players state the lord and copies
that they heard
from other players and then just to
decoding by majority
if they heard zero more than they heard
once then they will say the
bit of this player is one that's their
guess and if they heard once more than
they are zeros then they will guess that
the bit of the stair is
um one and
because you repeated log n times it it
works except with probability polynomial
small and it's in union bound
so the trivial protocol works if you
broadcast loading times
now the way gallagher gets his improved
protocol
of lord logan is it
uses the observation that not only do
the
parties correctly guess something that
is
direct except the probability polynomial
is small
the guesses of all the parties in the
system are independent
and this independence stems from the
fact that the noise is independent for
all the parties in the system
how do we use this well here's what
galileo says
galileo says that in stage x or in stage
guess
you did something pretty cool you were
able to guess the vet inputs of all the
other parties directly except the
probability polynomial is small
and now what you want to do is you want
to boost this test so that is direct
except the probability exponentially
small
how do you boost this well you fix an
error writing code c that takes
n bits so it can encode the vector x and
it has constant rate so let's say it
outputs 10 n bits with some constant
distance and what the parties do
is they all take the vector x that they
computed in stage yes and they encode it
using c
so all of them have 10 n bits now
the first player broadcast the first 10
bits of his encoding
the second player broadcast the second
10 bits of his encoding
and all the way till the last player
broadcasts the last 10 bits of his
encoding
and basically what we did here is that
if all the players agree on this vector
x
then together all they did was they
broadcasted c of x just that
they broadcasted ten coordinates each of
c of x
but what is cool is that
this broadcast was done using an error
correcting code
so if you decode from this code then
even if a constant fraction of the
coordinates are on you can still detour
correctly
and because players broadcasted an equal
fraction of coordinates a constant
fraction of coordinates can only be
wrong
if a constant fraction of the players
did not agree on x
now the probability that one player did
not get x directly is
polynomially small but the probability
that the constant fraction of players
by turn of down did not get x directly
is exponentially small there are n
players and by channel found
the probability that a constant fraction
of these players did not detect directly
will be exponentially smaller n
and this is the boost that gallagher
uses he says that you can actually boost
the failure probability from
polynomially small to exponentially
small
by using an error writing code and
sending it in a distributed manner
but why am i saying this is not login i
didn't even change stage broadcast
everything is still login and the
communication is at least n login
it turns out that
when you have a failure probability that
is exponentially small
you can divide the players into groups
of size log in so there will be n over
login groups
and what you can do is you can run this
protocol over the
login size group so all the n's will now
become log n earlier you were
broadcasting login times now you'll
broadcast log login times
earlier the total word was c from n to
10 and now it's log into 10 log n
and now the failure probability is
polynomial instead of exponential
but this polynomial probability is
enough to union bond over all the groups
so what you can do is by taking groups
like this you can only broadcast
log login times per player and still
union bound over all the troops and
therefore the
total communication in your protocol is
n log log n
and this is dalia's improvement
at first it may seem that this protocol
is also resilient to malicious players
and this is because um one may think
that in stage broadcast players are just
broadcasting independently so
clearly malicious players should not
affect this in stage yes players are
just guessing independently they're just
taking all the copies and seeing which
one
is the majority bit and this should not
be affected by the malicious players
and in stage boost you're using an error
correcting code so even if there is a
constant fraction of malicious players
no big deal you just have a larger
distance
and the malicious players can go into
the distance charity
so it's not easy to see what rates it's
actually very subtle
but what really breaks is that
in stage broadcast the players may not
broadcast
what we call pure bits
when you have an honest player then its
input is either a zero or a one
and if it's an input is zero then in
stage broadcaster will broadcast
zero lot log in times and in stage if
it's
input is one then it stays broadcast
will broadcast one lot log in times
now a malicious player is not required
to do this what the malicious player can
do for example
is that it can broadcast zero half the
time so let's say
um every r rounded broadcast is zero
in stage broadcast and broadcast one the
other half of the time
now when this happens
and the other players do majority based
decoding in stage yes then
they are equally likely to decode zero
or one because it just broadcasted zero
half the time and one the other half of
the time
so any other player in this troop made
decode to zero with probability half and
made equal to one with probability
half and therefore half the players in
this group will decode this bit to zero
and half the players in this group will
decode the bit to one and when they send
this encoding then half the players will
encode something that has zero in the
place of the malicious party and the
other half will
encode something that is one in that
place now
you now the earth writing code starts to
hurt you now the fact that you took an
air trading code
and you're encoding different things
means that you're sending completely
random coordinates
and these random coordinates will not
allow the failure property go down they
will not allow any boosting to happen
and that's where dalia's protocol will
break with malicious players
they will broadcast a mixed strategy
where they'll broadcast zero half the
time and one half the time and then
this encodings will be for uh mid
strings
so some players will be broadcasting a
string with zero some players will be
including a string with one
and then though boosting will happen you
will not get the
boost in the failure probability so you
will be stuck with the trivial
protocol which requires you to go login
times in stage broadcast
okay that's the problem and
it actually is not due to the fact that
you're detouring by majority it may seem
that
uh all of this was possible because you
know that uh the players will decode by
majority but even if you pick any other
threshold even if you say that
if you get more than 30 percent of the
ones then
i will decode to one and otherwise i'll
go to zero the
malicious players in stage broadcast
will just take that threshold as the
number of times they broadcast is one
so if you were to decode based on 30
then the malicious player will just say
okay i'll just broadcast one thirty
percent of the time
and i'll brought down zero seventy
percent of the time and again you have
an equal probability of either getting a
higher or lower fraction and
again you will send different strings
and everything will
start breaking down so how do we fix
this
well we observe that
when you do not have malicious players
then
this guessing in stage two was actually
helping you
and it was helping you because
in stage broadcast a player may either
broadcast
either all zeros or all ones let's say
broadcasted all once
then any other player in the group will
receive um it will have some noise but
most of the
bits that it receives from this player
will be once and only a small fraction
will be zeros
and what you do by guess is you decrease
the error
you had uh most of the bits to be one
and a small fraction was zero
and now what you do by this is when you
do a majority based tutoring now
everybody has all the bits to e1 so it
it decodes it to one exactly
and in the other case when most of the
bits are zero and some of the bits are
one it decodes it to zero exactly
and so guessing makes the um
estimate more close and more exact
but if you have a malicious player then
guessing actually makes it worse
you earlier say a malicious player was
broadcasting zero half the time and one
half the time
then when you guess uh sorry
before you guess every player receives
the count that is approximately
half zeros and half once but after you
guess
half the players are at one extreme
which is at absolute zero
and half the players are at the other
stream which is at absolute one
so guessing is actually making it worse
for malicious players
if there are malicious players and
our approach is to actually just delay
guessing a little bit
what we want to do is you want to run
stage broadcast this time we will have
root login rounds
um because the calculations will reveal
this parameter is optimized at
root login but we will not immediately
yes because guessing takes us farther
we'll first try to boost it
and this is still a problem because now
you're boosting something that is
um not exact it is not a it is you have
no guarantee that all the players will
be sending the same thing
and but what you do know is that if you
boost
before you guess then all the players
are boosting things that are
approximately the same
and we will use this we'll define a new
notion of error correcting towards that
is called locality sensitive
that can even boost things that are
approximately the same
and once we have boosted it we have a
probability that is polynomially small
we will all guess and everything will be
direct because now we can union bound
okay so this is the over i overall idea
let's go over it one more time
you have stage broadcast each party just
broadcasts its input
root logic times at the end of this the
players have root login copies of each
parties bit and it computes a count
which is the number of times it received
a one versus the number of times it
received a zero
now we know that these terms are close
together because the noise will only
change a small fraction
and we do not guess because it makes it
farther we or what we do is we use the
fact that we these towns are close
together
and we use a locality sensitive air
particle to boost these towns themselves
and now they're closer with very high
probability except with probability
power normally smaller than
and now that we have these boosted
counts we can guess and we can use the
union one technique
okay so everything boils down to
constructing these locality sensitive
electronic groups that work even when
the inputs are close together
and not exactly the same so let's define
them formally and see how to construct
them
now in a classic chiropractic door
you have a picture that looks something
like this you have the strings that you
want to encode these are
let's say um all bit strings
on and this and
what an educating code does it takes
these n bits and it gives you a slightly
larger range let's say 10 in bits
such that the entering of any two bit
strings
is now far apart and they differ in
constant fraction of the coordinates so
this picture looks parser
what we require from a locality
sensitive error correcting code
is something stronger from an operating
code we wanted that as soon as you have
two strings are different and one
coordinate your encodings are widely
different
here we want to respect the distance in
some way if your strings are close
together
let's say they are in this yellow
rectangle
then the encoders will also be somewhere
close they will be in this yellow
rectangle
and if your strings are far apart let's
say this string here the bottom left and
the top right in the yellow and green
then the encodings will be very far
apart you have a yellow rectangle it
will be somewhere here which is far
and the green thing will be somewhere
here which is very far from the yellow
rectangle
and this is what we want we want close
things to be mapped to close because our
accounts are guaranteed to be closed but
not exactly the same and we want far
things still be far apart because you
want to boost the probability
now this picture is actually
over simplifying things because what we
know is we have the triangle inequality
for example we know that if these two
things are close together then these two
things are also close together
and you cannot have such a neat
separation you cannot
have um these clean rectangles such that
all these images are far apart because
what you
you for all you know maybe you're in
this small rectangle here
and then for this rectangle the strings
are very different
so here needs to be taken in defining
these the right way
but the high level intuition will be
that if your strings which will be your
counts are close together
then the images will also be the
encodings will also be close together
and if the strings are far apart then
the encodings will be far apart
okay so let's see how to construct them
well our construction is showing
simply that if you take a random linear
combination of all the counts of all the
coordinates
in your string then you get something
that is locality sensitive
why is that well firstly what we want is
if your strings are close together
then your encodings are close together
and this is simply because of a churn of
bond if you take
each coordinate in your linear
combination randomly and independently
and all the quadrants are close together
then the sum will also be close together
the error will
converge and you will get something that
is closed so
this part is simply a turn of bound the
other direction is more involved
and here what you want to show is that
if you have two strings
that are far apart in the l infinity
sense so there is a coordinate where
the strings differ a lot let's say they
differ by delta
then this linear combination will also
be different by
approximately delta of two constant
factors
with constant probability so let's see
how this works
you have two strings that are far apart
and there's one coordinate where there
are delta apart
so let this be the first coordinate
and let all the other coordinates be the
rest of the coordinates
okay now
it is either the case that the
random linear domination when you only
consider the remaining coordinates not
the first coordinates
then it's either more than delta over
two with probability
more than one half or it's less than
delta over two with probability more
than one half
in the first stage when it's more than
delta or two with probability lower than
one half
whenever your random linear combination
does not take the first coordinate
which happens a constant fraction of the
time
then you get a linear combination then
you get a value that is
at least delta over 2 in
the difference which is by just our
assumption if the remaining coordinates
of something that is delta over 2 apart
and you don't take the first coordinate
then the overall thing is also delta or
two apart
on the other hand when the remaining
coordinates just something that is
less than delta over two apart then
with constant probability you take the
first coordinate
and this coordinate is delta apart so if
you were
inside delta over to an absolute value
before then
if you take this coordinate which
happens with constant probability then
now you're outside delta over two
and in either case there is either you
take this coordinator or do not take
this tolerance there is one setting
where
the value of the linear termination is
more than delta over two apart and this
is the claim here
we get something that is like that
infinity norm with constant probability
and when you plug this in you get a
definition of locality sensitive error
correcting codes
which we can use the boost accounts of
our protocol and we get something
that is end root login and solves with
exchange in the presence of noise
and malicious parties so that's it
that's my talk thanks for listening